(orchestral music)
- The main difficulties
of working with any
vulnerable or fragile work
of cultural heritage is the respect
you have to have for that object.
Technology is at a point right now
where we can record the
surface of an object
down to fractions of a millimeter,
and it's through this
kind of understanding
that allows you to communicate across time
and across cultures.
(frenetic piano music)
The task of heritage
protection and preservation
is a real challenge.
The mission of Factum Foundation
is to record cultural
heritage, so in the event
that there's a disaster or an accident,
we have the data to know what was there,
exactly as it is.
We're pioneering a number of methods
to return that information
into the physical world.
We're doing CNC milling.
We're doing 3D printing.
But we're trying to go beyond that.
A facsimile of the Borgherini Chapel.
The facsimile of the tomb of Tutankhamen
in the Valley of the Kings.
An exact facsimile of
Veronese's Wedding at Cana.
(dramatic orchestral music)
(crowd applauds)
The biggest project that's
going on at the moment
is an exact facsimile
of the tomb of Seti I,
which will be given to the people of Egypt
as soon as it's finished.
200 years ago the concern
was not one of preservation.
The concern was one of
Indiana Jones and discovery
and excitement and cultural acquisitions.
The tombs in the Valley of
the Kings lasted successfully
for 3,000, three-and-
a-half thousand years.
But since they've been visited,
they start to decline and decay rapidly.
I think the facsimile is
opening up a whole new level
of possibility for display, preservation,
conservation, restoration, communication,
dissemination of what's
important about these objects.
If only we can preserve it like it is
and document it and hand it
on to future generations,
then there's hope.
(soft orchestral music)
(electronic pulse)